il fait partie des 50 magasins sur 60
pas avoir ouvert mais ces salariés sont
sonnés ils ont le sentiment d'avoir été
bradés deux offres de reprise était en
concurrence le tribunal de commerce de
lille a fait le choix selon eux de
l'offre la plus dégradée en termes
d'emploi vous avez une société qui
s'appelle al khor qui est une
coopérative
donc effectivement avec six membres de
la coopérative il décide de prendre donc
50 magasins 460 salariés mais il met 23
millions d'euros sur la table et de
l'autre côté vous avez à des groupes qui
lui effectivement reprend 6 128 salariés
et qui ne met que 17 millions d'euros
sur la table
donc c'est pour ça que les salariés
effectivement souhaité plutôt à des
groupes parce que même après au niveau
opérationnel
on sent bien que al corse un peu plus
léger opérationnellement qu'avec ce
groupe qui a quand même une puissance de
feu beaucoup plus conséquente sans
véritable information sur la suite à
donner à leur emploie 70 salariés sont
restés chez eux et 10 magasins sont
restés fermés ce matin
une situation intenable pour les
syndicats qui demandent le concours du
ministère de l'économie on a tant fait
l'intervention du ministère de
l'économie
ça fait plusieurs fois qu'on demande à
être rencontré par bruno le maire
visiblement on doit pas l'intéressé donc
les salariés se sentent méprisés le
gouvernement ne peut pas laisser passer
un tel massacre
accumulant des pertes allant de 20 à 30
millions d'euros par an depuis 2000 17
l'enseigne a été placée en redressement
judiciaire
avec ce rachat par al khor mille
personnes risquent de perdre leur emploi
mais des recours sont déjà à l'étude